what is it that's so fascinating about
zombie movies maybe it's that they allow
us to contemplate humanity's darker side
or perhaps we'd like to imagine what we
would do during a zombie invasion either
way if you're hungry for some undead
essentials Netflix has plenty of tasty
options as if Australia wasn't dangerous
enough with its extreme terrain and
dangerous wildlife in cargo Australians
also have to deal with an outbreak of
zombies in the film a virus begins
spreading that turns us victims into
zombies within 48 hours of being
infected leaving Andy Kay and their baby
Rosie to take shelter on their houseboat
but when Kay makes a fateful trip to
scavenge for food and supplies on
another boat she's surprised by a zombie
and bitten and he gathers her family
together and embarks on a desperate
search for a hospital but as they
swerved to avoid hitting a man that they
crash and kay is impaled the sight of
this causes Andy to pass out he awakes
to find out that it's too late for Kay
she's already become a zombie and bites
him the rest of the film is a race
against time as he tries to find a safe
home for his daughter Rosie before he
succumbs to the virus and loses his
humanity along the way and he meets an
unlikely ally a young Aboriginal girl
named to me who could be helpful in
saving Rosie's life Rosie this way
South Korean cinema is definitely having
a moment right now if you enjoyed bong
Joon hos Academy award-winning drummer
parasite now is the perfect time to
check out other critically acclaimed
Korean films like the gripping zombie
thriller train to Busan trying to escape
from zombies in a city or through the
wilderness would be terrifying enough
but what if you had trapped on a moving
train with the undead charging after you
that's the basic premise of train to
Busan which begins with the divorce
workaholic and his daughter boarding a
train so that she can go see her mother
what starts as a fairly routine trip
quickly devolves into a living nightmare
when a young woman rushes onto the train
while she's turning into a zombie after
many more people are bitten the
passengers try to escape at a stop only
to realize that the cities are also full
of the infected as the train makes its
way to Busan everyone on board must
learn to fight back or they'll join the
legions of undead based on the video
games of the same name the Resident Evil
film franchise is perfect for fans of
zombies even if you've never played the
games you're be engrossed by these
stories of biologic
warfare gone wrong the third movie in
the series resident evil extinction is a
great zombie movie it is so right unless
the protagonists of the film's has been
battling with the Umbrella Corporation
since they buy weapons first sparked a
zombie apocalypse that consumed United
States then the entire world as the
movie begins Alice is traveling alone to
the desolate American Southwest making
occasional pit stops for supplies and
other necessary errands the umbrella
corporation has been producing
telekinetic clones of Alice while they
try to capture her but Alice discovers
that like her clones she's also
developed telekinetic abilities and she
makes her way to a potentially an
infected area in Alaska her telekinetic
skills add an entirely new dimension to
this installment and the franchise if
you're a fan of period dramas and samba
flicks it's time to cue up a rampant a
South Korean film that's packed with
world conflicts insane action and of
course hungry zombies during the Joseon
dynasty kingly joe's ruled a Serie C
question and he seems weak when compared
to the other leaders of the era his son
the Crown Prince devises a plot to help
protect the kingdom he'll secure
powerful new weapons from Europeans so
they can defend their Kingdom during the
meeting to acquire the weapons it's
revealed that the Europeans brought
something else along with them creatures
called night demons which are basically
zombies the Joseon army attempts to
destroy the European ships and take
their weapons but in the chaos a soldier
is bitten by a night demon and he brings
the affliction back to shore a zombie
infection soon spreads throughout the
kingdom and is overtaking everyone from
poor villages to guess within royal
circles with a zombie invasion going
into overdrive it's up to the crown
prince's brother Li Chun to save what's
left of his kingdom and to feed the
undead masses if you're in the mood for
a zombie film that feels more like a
rom-com than a horror movie then check
out life after Beth when sacs girlfriend
Beth passes away he's devastated and
wishes that he could tell her all of the
things he never got a chance to say but
when she miraculously comes back from
the dead it looks like he might actually
get the miracle he was hoping for at
first Zack is overjoyed to see her and
he thinks they can pick up their romance
right where they left off but as time
goes on it becomes clear that the Beth
who came back isn't quite like the Beth
that Zack once loved she's slowly
becoming a full-on zombie and can't
control her new desire to take a bite
out of anything within striking distance
and
Zack's hora other people in their town
also becoming infected now Zack will
have to decide if his love for Beth is
strong enough to overcome her love for
flesh stop Kyle I'm serious just let me
do this let me take her from you out of
your mind
in here alone and struggles to live off
the land in the wake of a zombie
invasion she clings to remind us of a
normal life and reflect some memories of
time spent with her husband and daughter
she misses human connections so badly
that she spends her time listening to a
radio broadcasting emergency messages
from a French station even though she
can't understand the language and is
hesitant to collect food from abandoned
homes where the infected could be hiding
however one day when she decides to take
a chance on it Jen's up finding two
other survivors on the road an injured
man named Chris and his stepdaughter
Olivia after an helps Chris recover and
get his strength back the two develop
romantic feelings for each other which
can get pretty complicated in the midst
of a zombie apocalypse but the big
question is can and really trust Chris
and Olivia or is her longing for human
contact causing her to overlook signs
that trouble is on the horizon check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about movies on
Netflix are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and to the bail so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]
you